quand la photographie amène à la poésie
l'association un temps poète s'associe à
ces des photographes de plaisir pour une
exposition les photographes proposent
leurs clichés sur une thématique et les
poètes sont inspire pour leur verre
c'est toujours la grande surprise en
fait dans les yeux des photographes de
voir comment leurs photos a pu être
interprétée et parfois la même photo par
plusieurs pour être dans plusieurs
regards sur leur premier regard
finalement cette année photos et poèmes
sont sur le thème de l'eau dans tous ses
états libre à toute interprétation je
chante pour vous aux femmes comme
l'oiseau des bois chantant le jour
naissant
je chante la joie qui rayonne en vous
setc des femmes dans l'eau un rapport
proche de la famille et l'obs que la fin
mais porteuse de vie et l'oci
défenderesse deviez donc je trouvais que
là il y avait vraiment une
une similitude un rapport direct les
deux associations plaisir oise
collaborent pour cette exposition depuis
neuf ans elle alimente chacune la
créativité de l'autre et ne sont pas en
nombre d'idées souvent ils nous ont dit
mais sans que l'on n'ait pu encore le
maître le mettre en oeuvre
c'est qu' il faudrait pouvoir aussi
faire le chemin inverse c'est à dire
qu'on leur proposait texte et que eux
trouve la photo 80 clichés accompagnés
de leurs mots sont exposés à la
médiathèque du château de plaisir
jusqu'à la fin du mois